we are focusing on the power of a hug
you recall last week our david begno
introduced us to a woman who started the
free mom hug movement well today we are
meeting a dad inspired by her actions
this is donnie stevens he drives to
pride events all across the state of
florida to give out free dad hugs and
this video montage of his hugs got more
than one
million views on tick tock this is so
cool donnie said he and his wife dawn go
to the events to make sure all kids all
the kids in the lgbtq community know
that they are loved and there's a little
bit of a sad twist to this they lost
their son spencer who was openly gay in
a car crash back in 2020 so they told us
that this is their way of honoring his
legacy and sharing their message of love
listen
sometimes somebody just needs a hug they
need a shoulder to cry on they need
somebody to talk to you never know what
somebody's going through just love your
people and love them fiercely and love
them unconditionally no matter what
no matter what no matter what the couple
plan to continue their tradition for
years to come showing us that a small
hug can go a very long way that's not a
small hug that's a good good size bear
hug though
that's a proper hug but i just love the
fact that they say you know a hug is
sometimes all someone needs to get
through the day yeah i agree totally
hook me up later
i don't know that is a responsible thing
to say right now